like do you know what we do for a living
yeah this is why we talk about these
things
yeah this is the podcast dude y'all
ordered the [ __ ] cheap cat william
that [ __ ] fired up damn
the game with that little pink tank
i'm not touching you dude
yeah i was on the slopes man y'all don't
know me like that you're sloping tell us
about you
man tell us about you you guys should do
more right here you can't say that
was that what you call i didn't know
that one
he don't know who
[Laughter]
whoa
[Music]
dude you're just throwing those things
out there it's disrespectful
bro is it slopeys is that no that's not
that's not it's just you know i don't
say that word
out of respect you know me because
they're in the [ __ ] room i didn't it
was just some boys hanging out
and we call them honestly gradients on
the street
what's that that's just a different kind
of slang baby you know
he's downhill you're sophisticated
bro there's a point where you're so
racist that you win the green jacket
you got that master's head mask
[Laughter]
[ __ ] rupaul who wants to fight this
so yeah what's that guy's name jake paul
rupaul dude jake paul versus rupaul
let's go let's go on god who wants to
see that oh
and rupaul's a big end yeah yeah
heavyweight huge
rupaul and that's the trick rupaul
people don't think it's a woman
there's no alcohol in here that's a man
baby okay thank you i'm good on that i
think
on that eggnog i'll cheers it thick yeah
man i'll cheers it's thick
i went mine a little little rum a little
rumpled stilt skin in this
egg are we getting drunk chin usually
has some booze in his backpack right you
drank last night did you
you could smell it no you look like it
no you look good i mean you look pretty
good yeah you got a drink last night no
you look like your special's trending
number one on netflix
you still took that uberx here though i
took uber
i came from santa barbara it's like two
hundred dollars in an uber x
yeah that's true but still you could uh
you were gonna you could do it
you could have done comfort you know
what like if you would have got him like
that are you really off netflix
yeah jump in my [ __ ] honda yeah dude
i'm gonna stay cheap though like that a
little bit yeah and you're not jewish
are we sure i no we're not sure no
i'm sure you know you know he's getting
into the business where people start
saying they might be a little bit jewish
you know he's in hollywood dude my
favorite uh meme that's out there man
and one it really just
is part of your journey man is you say
it's like netflix then netflix now
yeah when i said they were done yeah i
said i said they were going out of
business
yeah it went hard to paint bro i thought
they were we've all done it i didn't
think that i mean i thought when they
were still setting the cds bruh
that's when it was bad i didn't know how
business works now i didn't know that
like
you don't have to make money what do you
mean like businesses don't have to make
money like uber i don't think has made
any money
so i guess the model is you just keep
spending money until you're the only one
and then you can make all the money in
the space exactly what netflix is trying
to do
well i guess what that's what they've
been doing so i'm like initially i'm
like okay they're not making any money
and they're gonna lose all the shows
people watch i'm like nah it's not gonna
work
and then it worked and they're business
guys like how about you [ __ ] your mouth
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah a matter of
fact we were on a call
and when we were working on the deal and
i was like they're like hey we want to
introduce you to this person
and they're like you know they just make
sure uh you know nobody's saying
anything you know any disparaging
comments about
the [ __ ] you know the company what does
that mean disparaging comments like what
does it mean
yeah i don't know like it's done or
something
exactly what everyone like
so uh yeah and i was just basically like
i was like yeah it is what it you know
did you did you feel
weird because you're like kind of just
guessing no like what i said is i act
like it was my it was my plan the whole
time i was like yeah you got to stir up
order to catch fish
yeah okay you know you caught a big fish
i just heard charlotte say that on a
podcast once i was like oh that's good
when they offered it when netflix
offered we were kind of like i can't do
that
no because my whole thing is i just want
the most people to see it as possible
you know i mean like we were when we
were doing it for instagram and youtube
like we were getting like
like over three million views a week
right for like a weekly comedy clip
i don't know anything that does that for
a comedy clip no you know like like
hey i want this to be funny every week
like snl is not putting a sketch out
every week does that this three million
views funny
so i was like okay boom everybody on
youtube and instagram knows what this is
but there's a whole lot of people
that maybe aren't like
[ __ ] i had family members hit me up and
they said congratulations on your
engagement and netflix
damn that means they didn't congratulate
me on my engagement
yeah and then when netflix happened they
were like oh this is worth texting yeah
they almost don't know
they almost didn't take you seriously
but look that's the climb i think it's
like it's kind of like holly it's funny
because once you
do enough on your own then hollywood
comes around yeah like then you're in
the club
as they should right that's their
business that's when you learn oh
hollywood isn't like
sometimes it feels and to me it's felt
like this sometimes it's this thing that
they don't want you it keeps you out but
i think they just they have their
favorites but if you're not one they'll
still give you a shot once you have
enough of your own climb exactly
what's weird is by the time they give
you a shot you really don't need it
right so it's like i guess i'll do it
but you'd be fine either way i'm fine
either way
this is so more people see it it's fun
don't don't worry it's fun and
of course these things are like exciting
because people get so excited
financially is cool but like financially
i'm good i'm not trying to like brag
whatever but like
i've been good like i'm good bro you
know tim dillon but you're doing good
i know what i mean i'm not know fancy
restaurants all the time yeah
tim told me i was like dude you're
looking kind of think he goes this ain't
fat this money bro
that's money bro yeah that's the real
sam
that's what mine is too you know but
yeah man just get out there get it to
the people man that's all
you had that video create create create
i was uh i watched that the other day
and i was like holy [ __ ] i've wasted
this whole pandemic
and i could have just watched this video
which i saw
a few months ago but now man
dude i was this whole pandemic two
people that have really just been
keeping me and
uh comedically feeling good at you and
tim dillon man i swear to god bro yeah i
love too
man he's got great stuff man yeah man
it's uh it's great
stuff so what else is going on dude are
you still doing fashion because
sometimes i see fashion sometimes i
don't
right now he got it all right we just
did a drop that jordan
we did that [ __ ] yeah god we just
take jordan and travis scott [ __ ] and
flip
it yeah that's what we do off-white yeah
let's be honest bro
yeah who's eating more travis scott uh
meals
at mcdonald's white people or more urban
type of people
white people oh white people yeah i
don't do black people know about travis
scott yeah they do
okay yeah yeah but they're not really
onto us like lester holt
like they're there for but they ain't
really they're not they're not riding
with them
there's something over here dude what's
up
sean king yeah that's a real tan black
guy
that's a real damn like but he's black
because you're looking at this you're
black but then you're like are you
are you you are those ears those aren't
black ears dude
that's richard dolezal bro
that's who it is oh he's serious man
that ain't damn
uh whatever y'all said lester holt bro
that's a lie right there he should do
one episode finding his parents bro
first 48 fighting his parents dog
is he half or is he full i don't know
what does he say on
wikipedia he claims full and he's not
fooling anybody
yeah we need to hook him up with gabby
lamb's lip guy
oh that's true who's gabby lamb she was
uh sitting in your spot a couple
episodes ago
okay she was here last week she went to
a with dill
and she and what she has nice lips she's
doing she's got them got lip injections
oh things done by like done done like
they're fresh off the table can we see
him straight from there to here oh i got
him done at a dark competition dog these
dark competitions these
she might have said she she might have
done too much how do you guys feel about
the lip injections
do what you do and if you need them
that's the only plastic surgery i'm like
yo
go do it yeah if you have nothing you do
them you got those little pencil lips my
mom has no lips she's like a like a bird
oh wow and does she want to get it done
no she's you know except
if you're getting a bj it's like doing
bumper bowling remember bumper bowl yeah
it worked it's like yeah yeah
it was way better with the [ __ ]
bumpers it's some [ __ ] where they put
like tubes on the side so you can't have
kids oh god yeah it's for adults too
brendan i mean if you're real shitty
ebola
yeah yeah bryant gumbel's another one
same
same club i saw brian gumbel once where
you do
eating soup man i thought he was uh oh i
hate to say this but i thought he was um
a mod
[Laughter]
the same [ __ ] though come on now dude
that guy's a legend dude a martial shot
is a legend
richard is a legend man and i felt bad
back in the day what was it a reading
rainbow
no no what no
oh that's right what that's right
bring up the guy from reading rainbow
dude this
is
and this guy died no he's got the host
of jeopardy
he might be the host of jeopardy oh
really yeah i thought that was good
i'm addressing i did nba inside stuff
yeah yeah that stuff was so
sick they should have made a movie
i wanted them to make nba inside stuff
the movie
i think they did did they do i don't
know what they did summer sanders
was his uh co-host oh yeah blonde pizza
oh he's married to
what's her name that played uh uh gabby
uh
uh volleyball playable yeah she married
uh the what the
that played bill cosby wife on the cosby
show her right there
she's got it fine boy gabby this is
summer sanders who
who are you guys talking about yeah i
mean yeah forget
who i was talking about who's summer
remember sanders got them little
but what's up ahmad rashad's best
friends oh he's he's boys with jordan
remember he's all up in the
documentary all of it yeah acting like
the best friends kind of
[Music]
he's in the back videos damn bro it's
almost christmas man that's
crazy oh my god it's christmas you know
what happens around the holidays
i know what happens man people get sad
no
people get better too they get lonely oh
yeah people do get lonely we need to
talk somebody but quit talking to your
friend maybe they're with their family
on the holidays and they can't get back
in time
and some people's friend is an idiot yep
so that's the thing you talk to them
forever but you're not getting better
and that's why
what we're offering you today is better
help yeah start communicating under 48
hours it's not crisis line it's not
self-help we're talking about real
professional counseling done securely
online yep there's a broad range of
expertise available which may not be
locally available that's a thing
sometimes if you look around your house
or around your apartment you can't get
any help
and it's worldwide baby worldwide better
help is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors if you're
not feeling your counselor
all right better help once you start
living a happier life
right now stay on earth stay lit baby
that's what we're talking about go to
betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people
taking charge of their mental health
and we have a special offer too yeah
special offer for the king and the sting
squad you guys get ten percent for your
first month at betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s pg baby praise y'all man i'll
tell you what'll give you
athletic browns baby dude them green
athletic greens dog my gosh schultz is
going to try it out on his little gift
he doesn't know it yet but he's getting
a nice little gift of
athletic greens man we talking about
athletic greens the most
comprehensive daily nutritional beverage
i've ever tried
hands down dog i've put a lot of things
in my mouth we're talking about one
tasty scoop of
athletic greens contains 75 vitamins
that scoop daddy they call them man beat
the cold season
get that immune system popping yeah dude
you don't want to show up to a party or
show up to
2021 with a weak immune system you over
there one of your arms is getting
smaller than the other one
you shaking yeah you got moss growing on
one side of your back bro tighten
up dude athletic greens is doubling down
on supporting
the immune system during the winter
months they are offering our audience
free one year supplies of vitamin d and
five free travel packs dang you love d
simply visit athleticgreens.com
cats and join the health experts
athletes and health conscious people
to make your life better again visit
athleticgreens.com
cats get your free year supply of that d
baby and free five packs of travels
packs today
amen dyslexia yes it packs twice
dude who are you i want to know because
you are really you're kind of covert
you're almost like a
russian spy in the urban community i
feel like all right so
who have you met that's like who have
you met bro
you know what i'm saying dude who have
you met that i know
that i would be that we would probably
be afraid of like who the killers that
i've met
yeah anybody laughing i haven't met any
like real like shot caller type dudes
suge knight no no this this guy's not
tough
but have you met takashi 69 out there no
i haven't met takashi oh weird
yeah i wanted to meet him i was
fascinated by him have you seen the
documentary
yeah yeah he did for hip-hop what the
paul brothers are doing for boxing
like he just was calling people out and
he knew that they weren't going to do
anything
and trolling everybody yeah they're not
gonna do anything all this attention
exactly when you troll the super
gangsters and they don't do something
super gangster
you look like the super gangster because
they can't these days anyway because
it's all
yeah well the fats see everything
exactly like your instagram is
crazy these kids are like they're
rapping about the crimes they do and the
feds will just listen to the song that
they posting their answer like all these
people got locked up for the ppe [ __ ]
the ppp or whatever it is uh the lone
child thing because they were
bragging about getting buying ferraris
and lambos wait who did that
there was a
cause they got those relief loans for
their businesses but they were like
lying about them so they give them like
two million and they're buying
lamborghinis and posting on the gram
wrapping up
tom segura doing that i think wasn't he
started
[Laughter]
yeah man but isn't it whatever bro i'm
kind of like okay with that like get
your money
bro and it's also i think you hit the
nail on the head man and
uh it's just interesting that that's
what yeah you could talk [ __ ] to anybody
and if they're not gonna do anything
nobody's doing anything anymore takashi
69 went to
south side chicago and feeding
homelessness was saying
suck my dick that's it everybody he went
to oh block
everybody and he did it at like there
like he came in three in the afternoon
it was like
okay like he still was there is that is
that the safe time
yeah i'm not going there any time yeah
he would go into like an abandoned
bakery and give out hundreds of dollars
to everybody
it was kind of sad because he was making
like kids in brooklyn look like he was
in like peru
yeah like he was giving five dollar
bills and kids in brooklyn were going
crazy he's like you live in new york you
paid 2
000 for rent yeah what was going on
it's embarrassing guys but and then he
and then now everyone like snoop
everyone's talking [ __ ] about him
because they're saying he's a snitch
everyone still [ __ ] with him yeah he
gets views oh man you bring him on
anything he's good did he go back to
jail i couldn't figure that out he's
now what about um here's a question
right here from somebody who obviously
this is undecided if he wants to be you
or nick
who's obviously not going to play the
extra superman
this is our uh christmas episode so we
have some christmas related topics
okay cool you're okay
you have staying glad to be here thanks
for the invite
uh listen i got a king understanding for
y'all
decorating for the holidays he barely
opens it i don't mean
decorating i'm sorry it looks like it
hurts yeah
inside of your wire i think he's wearing
them all right
so i just recently got back from college
just graduated
and i'm back living with the parents
north pole state
and this is just what i got to deal with
i mean there's so many decorations
there's decorations hiding decorations
oh this is just mom's house
so i'm just wondering guys
uh you can't understand it decorating
the inside of your home for the holidays
love you guys gang gang
buzz buzz that's the most relaxed person
i ever seen
his energy he went so slow it was three
minutes couldn't fit that on instagram
yeah we got
if we got in the first five years he
wouldn't even open his jaw
to speak he was like
he sounded like an aging boxer that was
unbelievable
that was unbelievable that he thought
that he should have that whole video
played
out of things but i couldn't stop
watching because i was like am i gonna
see his tongue or not
i don't think he has a tongue that guy i
think he's hiding the fact he didn't
have a tongue
look at him see if he has a tongue he's
a shark bro yeah right
look at this i've never seen a shark
tongue there's no there's no shark tone
my boy mike cannon mike feed i think
we're talking about that they're like
they don't have tongues it's just a hole
yeah why do they need a tongue it tastes
good right if it's there
no no time no no it would be cool if our
tongues were flavored though wouldn't it
[ __ ] flavored tongues get you a
little barbecued tongue a little
barbecue time i just have it all day
were you playing ball
so you could take that barbecue ball
done people like damn what you eating
you know like i'll just have a little
bit of myself
uh that green bread did your girl did
your fiance decorate the
apartment yeah yeah yeah we did a little
christmas tree action
this shit's dope chicks [ __ ] if you got
kids you definitely need to do it oh
yeah yeah
look i'm about the christmas spirit man
me too let's get into it i mean it
doesn't look like it today i know we're
doing a [ __ ] christmas episode but
like let's go
no you didn't bring any fashion for us
even though we've watched a million
stories
i was gonna send you guys passion i had
it all like printed and everything and
then i remember i asked you for your uh
the address i was like where can i send
some stuff yeah what happened bro a
global pandemic
i literally have it at the studio like
putting these like cool uh plastic
containers yeah it's [ __ ] up pandemic
hit
pandemic kit and then what you've just
been selling it to everybody else
yeah because my thick voice is
what's going on why everybody need free
shirts you're right bro
come on all right do you did you
decorate the place in nashville
no no uh i decorated the studio we just
had santa claus on actually nick you
want to pull up that up real quick yes
sir dude we had the real santa cam
wow and he was dude from a mall in
nashville or what he works at a smoothie
king four days a week
but he is so talented this is a sad
story
wait till you see this man yes yes he's
talented this man is owned
before you play this i don't trust
anybody who wants to play santa claus in
a mall this is also said this
next level podcasting cause like we're
podcasting watching
oh damn whoa what is this
what do you say
[Laughter]
can we make the leah jokes about a guy
who has kids sit on his lap
we can't do that i don't want it
you guys are [ __ ] up buy some
fashion you freaks buy some [ __ ]
fashion
but dude this is what it feels like when
you meet him that's the look you have on
your face and that's him bro look how
big he is
he's almost seven feet tall and he works
at a smoothie king he works outside of
one
[Laughter]
oh he doesn't work smoothies he's not
man he's a hired man
he's a higher guy did he come through
with the reindeer uh no he's but he said
that they have some reindeer that are on
jv he went dude
he played the whole time bro he's saying
there's no doubt that
santa was he fifty dollars an hour or
some [ __ ] uh i think he was about three
hundred dollars for the visit oh
damn santa yeah you're starting to think
your tongue does taste like barbecue
sauce bro cause you've been licking your
lips
yeah well you said some of that eggnog
right over there brother
y'all need to get that that taste talks
did you lose taste did you lose taste
when you got that rounds
yes you did cause he don't [ __ ] know
dude and still like yeah
and still ate fat and still i know i'm
addicted to food i still ate fat
you ate fat i i couldn't taste anything
oh material
i still ate like a fat ass yeah wow no
sense yeah i was wearing pizzas every
day
oh yeah burritos every day yeah more
spicy you get the hot sauce yeah yeah
yeah yeah real spicy
dump hot sauce on everything do not say
who has a good hot sauce i'm not even
joking i thought it wasn't going to be
any good
justin pour ace new hot bro i did not
you know people said you know we sent
each other [ __ ] all the time and it's
garbage bruh yeah
and then um you know because i've used
to do those cbd milkshakes you got me on
dude
my [ __ ] back has been hurting since i
drank really yeah skin looks better
though well but the doctor said they
might have metal in it
but this is the best 12 dollars hold on
this is the third
episode i don't know if he's giving you
a [ __ ] chair this is the third
episode in a row right you can put it on
salad this [ __ ] is
good use code tpw yeah
actually there is no code but it is good
bro but anyway
um so what's going on are you getting
married you're boys with him yeah he's a
legend man yeah he's great man
i mean he's got a fight coming up in
january january that's connor right
is that a tricky fight for him him yeah
really cause conor's arms are just long
the way that they sometimes the way
people's arms meet up with other
people's heads is different
yeah for sure and some some are better
at meeting up with other people's heads
yeah yeah you're still trying to bet on
that dustin you know i love you i know
you watch the show be trying to bet on
that
yeah man what do you want to be i'll lay
a grand on it right now whoa
let's go how do you say two grand oh
grand one grand and i want [ __ ] cash
on the show dog
bring [ __ ] cash okay don't be trying
to give those [ __ ] cashiers
who are you send me [ __ ] theo merch
who are you going for here's a
here's a grand and [ __ ] hitter gear
don't do that [ __ ]
give me that real [ __ ] uh i think connor
wins that you got connor
and i love dustin yeah i like dustin too
man
and here's nick going to his own website
that he built
from the ground up nick lost me over
four thousand dollars this year
for real but his own return on
investment has been a couple of grand i
think i just picked the wrong ones
i'm headed into 2021 down eight units at
the moment we got one event left so
let's get into black
let's go in the black baby
yeah talks about that like you didn't
hear that you often hear that like uh
like we use black as a term for like
scary or dark or whatever like there's a
negative connotation but when your
business is profitable what is it
in the black in the blog we gotta start
promoting that a little bit more no we
don't mention that
we don't mention that enough yeah come
on now now was new york with all the
the yeah don't do this
don't do this new york don't do this
don't do this don't do this
don't do this because you don't even
compare new york to out here this dog
[ __ ]
we're dog [ __ ] yo everybody's closed
we're the reason why we're shut down
our [ __ ] bro dude you're yeah yeah
you do what people tell you
you do what people tell you bro our
governor said shut it down and you guys
are like
you guys shut it down no we don't shut
it down we don't listen there's no one
that started this pandemic
old people we don't listen to nobody
miley cyrus dog can't stop nobody put
their
parents in that fight nobody put their
parents there
cuomo pushed everybody oh you're sick
nobody from new york put their parents
at old people's home it's wrong it is
wrong it's wrong and if you care about
your grandparents then you ain't letting
them die out in some shed somewhere on
the suburbs let them die in your shed
yeah let them die your [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's new york no i'm just saying i'm
here
everything's closed even in my hotel wow
i can't get snacks yeah
he stays in the house it's upset he'll
be don't go bad on there doug
you're here yeah we go to nashville for
a reason alex media what's up
it's so bad i love you man this is my
squad you know this is my squad
good to see you guys thank you for
coming in don't you don't hit that
number one on netflix she comes with an
entourage
you got to come with the people come the
entree thank you so much
i've been different bro i changed bro i
changed it up
i can't believe you're how you are
[Laughter]
because there's nothing attached to it
but
if i'm offended you're like well i
didn't know that's what you thought yeah
that's whatever you want to make of it
no but for real it's too shut down over
here y'all gotta crack [ __ ] open you've
been outside you don't even belong here
dog
you're out here biking every single day
that's not a cali way of doing [ __ ]
i'm living you're living everybody out
here not living he belongs in rochester
where else
brownsville yeah maybe brownsville
yeah i could see you over there fighting
crime mm-hmm
you look like a bunch of these [ __ ]
florida dog florida
defensive you could throw that's a thing
that's a ride
offensive dude you're oh [ __ ] though
who is this handsome man this is cats in
the wild brendan
interior decorating dang damn
uh schultz looks very confused people
send in he kind of got
he kind of got the fatty
what is it what's going on
come on come on bro that's it but what
is that that's bobby lee
people our fans send in uh sightings
they see in
in the wild of people on this show and
someone thought that was brendan doing
some interior decorating
[Music]
you guys got like a real show like this
is produced and stuff
it's a real show man look this is the
next level i thought we were just out
here talking [ __ ]
you guys got sick the same new york [ __ ]
no you guys are next level with it
the same you all changed bro y'all
i don't know i think i got angry this
past year i don't know what happened it
could have been all the turmoil out of
nah you've been angry since i met you
have i really yeah i think also y'all
took away the tfatk belt so i didn't
have any place to put that anger also
took away that strap after i [ __ ]
it's a new belt now is it
yeah well you don't you didn't say
anything or
well we had to rebrand you know yeah
well it's your fault episode 24 of king
and the sting was
uh called rat rage because theo came in
really angry on that one
i love it what were you charged up about
this is i love it
all year name name something is there
something that's
really [ __ ] ticking you off like what
is the thing that's just driving
you want me to answer there's some i say
it huh i'd say
just like what's specific there's
something there's got to be a specific
thing
give me all life that chess the chess
girl on netflix the chess thing
oh that was yeah that helped me a little
you like that that guy you threw okay
i threw a tough [ __ ] couple days yeah
what's got me so angry i don't know bro
i think i j i don't know i this year i
just got angry but there's something
dude too much information out there i
think sometimes it's just too much to do
and too much information and too much
like you don't think covert made you
upset like coven made me angry the
isolation of it
the the way our society especially to
your point
la reacted yeah yeah and we're just like
okay and
shut everything that's exactly whoa soft
soft yeah yeah
soft people driving nuts yeah like in
tennessee they're doing you can do front
side piggy back rods over there
dude out there
living well yeah yeah
can i get a piggyback yeah
[Laughter]
look up buddy
and don't worry about a mask either
he's just staring down now we're in
front
she's just
just don't look at me while we ride no
that's gay
that's where it becomes good piggy back
without eye contact
[ __ ] close their eyes oh yeah
just look over my shoulders
take a nap take a nap look over my
shoulder
praise god bro andrew what can we expect
out of your show man what can what can
people expect out of us i know that's
just kind of a general question but what
do you think like
could make this show that you're doing
now have like longevity and stuff i hope
people get pissed
i don't want it to be a show that we do
every week
i just want it to be like a piece you
know yeah and if i if
you know we'll see about doing it is it
in traditional uh
like a traditional special like so it's
basically like the the turn your phone
videos i was doing mm-hmm
and it's a monologue and then the
monologue has this like dance with the
pictures
you know so like you the jokes are kind
of like punctuated by the pictures and
like uh yeah so it's just i don't know
we do uh four 15 minute segments of it i
watched it last night it was great
oh thank you yeah yeah i appreciate that
yeah what's up with that sweater though
i got you bro
all right yeah charlemagne was like dude
if people aren't upset by this i'm gonna
be pissed
so you're paying attention all of it i
mean like those are the best reviews
like for comedy you don't want
the reviewers to go oh my god this is
great because if people go oh my god
this is great from a reviewer it means
nothing
like oh you understand like i don't
watch things because a reviewer says
they're good
but if somebody goes this was the most
offensive thing ever and they're a
reviewer i'm in
immediately watching give me the time
stamp i'm going for it so like
the goal is because if you're a comedy
reviewer in my opinion even if you're a
viewer who has said nice things to me
you're the lowest form of human being
because
anybody like look with basketball you
can analyze basketball
because you're not six six and you just
can't do it yeah it's like michael
rappaport boom
wait yeah what do you mean i think it is
though oh no yeah because he talks [ __ ]
about lebron right now he's always out
there like they can't he doesn't [ __ ]
with a big three
yeah yeah so but my point is like okay
you could analyze that
but you can't physically do it but if
you're a comedy reviewer and you know
what the best comedy is
by all means show us what it is like
there's nothing stopping you could talk
yeah go get updates
yeah get up there just do it yeah
absolutely so like just do
it you can just like just do it like
just please
if you know exactly what it is you can
keep that laptop and get it up there
yeah yeah follow or follow follow
because i can't wait to see what perfect
comedy is yeah
so our goal for the reviewers is
scathing review
that's like oh my god it's the most
offensive things are so [ __ ] up
absolutely
absolutely 100 so if that happens with
them because the people are gonna
show the love because the people don't
have an attention to rally around not
even my fans like the average person
it's so good
and i'm not saying that to be like
braggadocious but like we put so much
[ __ ] work into this bro because i was
trying to book you for a hot second but
i'm working 19 hours bro i couldn't i
could he goes 15 minutes straight
just [ __ ] dude what's funny is when
you when you were releasing those clips
on instagram like flip your phone i was
jealous when that happened
god bless is that where the anger comes
from huh i'm glad now
okay you all you were very supportive
you hit me up i had a buddy who wanted
to do it yeah you did a a friend
a friend of ours we all know you didn't
say anything about it you were like you
ever been to nashville i think
[Laughter]
they call me scat williams
i had a friend who wanted to do like a
take on that
like what uh schultz is doing like yeah
no doubt have you ever seen what schultz
is doing he's like
uh no i went go look and he looked at me
oh i'm not going to do that anymore i
don't have that
so how does that break down so you have
you know you have uh you guys here today
do they help uh put that together and
stuff so yeah there was three for this
one um
there's three writers and me so the four
of us would basically it's like this is
so nerdy when i describe it it's like
the least fun it's like game of thrones
we like it though no no you guys can we
like to see how the sausage is made
yeah but like basically what we do is we
write
a term paper with no jokes oh yeah right
it's literally like
like popping top topics like currently
literally we take the topic
we talk to all the experts tell us yeah
and then we write a [ __ ] term paper
and then we turn every line into a joke
and then we do a whole pass with the
pictures
you could watch it just seeing me and
then you get one version of it and then
you could not look at me and just look
at the pictures and you get a whole
different version of it
so like people are like they're like i
have to watch it four times is that the
other
and it's like we throw all these little
tricks in there if you do watch it i
guess what i would say is um
watch it all the way to the ends of the
credits
that's all i would say okay got it
what's dope is it's perfect timing too
because every
everybody's been watching that [ __ ]
because it's the holidays everyone's
chilling and you're locked in you can't
go nowhere
did you see uh that this uh january 15th
i'm doing a live show at 8pm eastern
central
[Laughter]
and you can get tickets online just
throw that out
that was yeah i did see that yeah very
cool
[Laughter]
between hot sauce and his live show here
we go
what's this we're trying to cash out
dude you see some people trying to cash
out
they're selling everything right now i
think some people love
yourself
look man sometimes you're looking at you
know you go outside your door and you
try to find something to eat like the
old days you might hunt something
hunt your little raccoon hunt you a
little salamander bro barbecue that
squirrel
not anymore dude with hello fresh we're
talking about hello fresh
sends food to your crib no more hunting
no more going hungry anymore dude all
you got to do is go to hellofresh.com
80 cats use the code 80 cats to get 80
off including free shipping dude i'm
telling you this a
squirrel is just a rat with that booty
scarf baby dog
so what i'm telling you guys right now
is sometimes you make a meal for
somebody and they come over they say
this is garbage they won't eat it
they say they get sick or they got
vertigo or something and they sneak off
not anymore man but what happens with
this type of meal is that
it's all organized they got a chart it's
got onion
they got a little bit of onion in there
they got maybe some barbecue sauce they
got a pork cutlet you talking about that
pre portion ingredients
high quality you can make the meals
they're delicious all right
bro you try new stuff man you could be a
one-armed blind dude
in a damn pool full of quicksand you
could figure this meal out
hell yeah we talking about meals in
under 20 minutes low calorie vegetarian
kid approved whatever you want
we got it for you man hellofresh is
changing the way you
eat your food and they are chef crafted
this isn't just miscellaneous this isn't
somebody's cousin you know
trying to tell you what they think they
ate this is something classy and we have
a special deal for you guys
right now and that deal is
hellofresh.com
80 cats okay ats yep use code 80 cats
get 80
off in free shipping yeah merry
christmas
look it's that time of year and i see
you're freaking my main dog
yeah it's just been looking tragic
online bro but you finally starting to
tighten up a little bit
man cause you're getting that growth and
how are you doing dude with hams oh who
is he
yeah it's my friend hams who is he
dude you know 66 men said their loser
here by 35
and once it's gone it's gone daddy so
what who's helping you
his name's hymns dog who is him i don't
wanna tell you his name
for hims.com one stop shop for hair loss
skin care
and sexual wellness for the bros it's
time to write a new chapter
one in which you got a full set of hair
yep and when was the last time you took
care of your dick think about that
you're running around using your dick
and not taken care of taking it for
granted where you're taking it
yeah and look that thing ain't a damn 88
uh
chevrolet um charger
ram charger so what i'm saying is today
hems is giving you their best offer
yet if you're not happy with your
results after 90 days hems will give you
a full refund and that's as much refund
as you can have as a complete refund
full
that's for hims.com kats
go to forhems.com k-a-t-s
to get the uh opportunity after within
90 days get that full refund
yes also prescription projects require
an online consultation with a health
care provider who will determine if the
prescription is appropriate
restrictions apply see website for full
details and important safety information
remember that's for hims.com cats oh god
what's this little young honey saying so
we asked a couple weeks ago
uh we wanted to see who's out there our
fans and get some new blood in the
culture corner just uh
see see who's out there and this was one
of our uh can we just pause for she's
got very in uh very sweet looking girl
but it's on my teeth yeah there's i feel
like she's missing
the teeth that go after the big teeth
it's all big teeth
no it looks like all big teeth no fangs
are coming too quick
i think she's missing these two teeth no
i think she has all big teeth she's fine
yeah really yeah i'm not mad at her okay
no i'm not mad at her
i'm just i can't stop looking at that
yeah bone hinge baby it looks good to me
i feel hey brandon it's anna from south
florida ooh too far
uh miami right now vernon this would be
crazy
to be in the culture corner
hey there you go um all that all that i
speak spanish
i am the funniest person in my friends
group if
i do say so myself and um i have done a
few open mics
however due to the pandemic i can't
really do that anymore
so i just love this opportunity to meet
you guys and be a part of a show that i
love
um you know i got them haters
she threw that out there's in the back
so uh game game
did she say there's a trunk in the back
yes well god damn
i got the j in the tray baby hell yeah
um
what do you think chelsea i i don't know
what's going on
do we make fun of them do we just listen
you can light them up whatever you want
it's submit at your own risk i think you
light them up if you think that's what
they deserve
is that the culture of the show yes oh i
understand these are your biggest
supporters you know what i mean
like everybody gets i look at it you
look at it i think that we don't
roast them but we roast them if there's
something to be roasted like
there's not much there's yeah she has
the same front teeth all around but yeah
yeah
yeah many teeth she has
pixar teeth she looks
like the dad from up look at her teeth
go back to the beginning of the video
it's not bad dude i want to see her chew
into a baguette and just
tear that [ __ ] apart
oh
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
doctor from not the doctor the scientist
yeah incredible yeah
man damn that the accuracy but yes that
is her 100 percent
that's great that is [ __ ] but no
disrespect obviously
this is with all due respect
respect you know that we're saying that
your teeth [ __ ] suck
[Laughter]
they don't suck though they don't suck
yeah
this is [ __ ] like this is type 2 leo
what's up brendan what's up theo i'm
skylar i'm spencer and we're identical
twins and we're from wakanda illinois
and no not the black panther wakanda
even though that would be pretty cool
i think we'd be perfect for the culture
corner especially being identical twins
we've experienced a lot of things
through our lives and uh
we definitely have some stories yeah and
i think we bring a lot to the table
don't touch me bro double gang double
buzz
oh wow hopefully the boys don't out
there right now them boys don't get
covered
oh this is this feels uncomfortable to
look at
twins are a little scary to look at
twins they shouldn't be there don't
believe my arch nemesis were twins
growing up bro
yeah everybody's was you mean your arch
yeah more than one
arch nemesis
you had two people that looked exactly
the same they weren't they're my cousins
and me and my brother would fight him on
spot
what's up raymond and daniel what the
[ __ ] up now doug
raymond is one of them that's an adult
named raymond yeah it's a little too old
for a kid
weird a little too old baby raymond
but these guys can we talk about these
guys first of all that picture in the
back bro it's terrifying
epic look at that [ __ ] right there
with their mouths open
oh my god they would be good dude i
always
hey if you're looking for a tongue there
you go andrew bro yeah i got that that
tongue's been through some work right oh
that's a b flavor who do they look like
nice beef fliver baby they look like
they look like someone yeah
i think the type two leo but they do
look a little they are a little like the
dad from up almost like
they could have been his son the head
shape was similar to the dad from up
show that we had just seen like
someone yeah damn in the back they look
fine as hell sitting in the back the
cowboys you know
that's that la [ __ ] coming back out play
[ __ ] bro you can say kids are fine as
[ __ ]
no dude
look at this little bad [ __ ]
i'm an adult bro but show me that
[ __ ] work boo boo right here
bam son okay yo why would you post this
bro
look at this shawty looking back at it
yeah she's looking
back guys come on bro that's
disrespectful bro you can't post your
kid like this bro
[Laughter]
looking back at it that's wild you got
that amelia earhart briefcase what's she
working on
i'm out i'm out there for this oh you're
wild
y'all messed up bro y'all messed up
dude and now these little bad biscuits
right here should [ __ ] fist fight
i always thought you watched this fight
yep and one of them needs to go
somebody gotta go yep battle of the
death that's how i do it
but look man i would love i think these
guys would be interesting to have in
here
they have good personalities yeah did we
say they have to be in l.a
yeah and i mean i was just going picking
the best submissions like seeing if like
you guys loved one who knows but i like
both of them so far well
they're cool i'm on the other chick with
the hitters i'm uncomfortable by it but
now would you have are y'all going to
have guests are you guys having guests
on your show
man we do i haven't watched it yet i'm
going to watch it wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait what
brilliant idiots i know podcast show on
netflix
oh no that's just like a rant okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah thanks for being prepared
son
i'm the only one that watched it last
night told me today he's like when does
it come out i'm like
two days ago i thought it came out today
that's why i thought he came out today
i thought he came out i paid it yeah i
followed i followed thank you bro
i'm not on social media i don't [ __ ]
know you're just posting your kid
twerking
social media what are you talking about
it was his birthday
that's what
in the morning
i feel like she needs like an actual
woman like in the room with her
mm-hmm is she going balance no she said
yeah i'm totally serious about going to
la like you might think it's crazy
but i have an auntie there and i'm so
bored with craved like
at this point i'm like why not so i'd be
there i'd quarantine and i'd be in that
culture corner
um also side night i know all 70 of the
attractive girls
if say if it needs something you know if
everything's booked out
yeah you do that
i'm saying bro you'll pick her up from
the airport i'm not doing all that yeah
you
are there you are i provide grounds all
right are you
single i'm single yeah oh [ __ ] have you
been shooting your shot during this
little lockdown
let me think man not really no no no
nashville honeys
i've been on a couple dates that's it
have you busted cheeks
i've been jerking off no but
not a ton i got four days right now oh
that's what's okay there you go there we
go
yeah bro huh what jokingly no watching
yourself
again thousands of times
you keep doing it that's sick really
yeah you're right it's crazy i think if
you watch somebody do that you'd feel so
sorry for them if you saw him every
night doing that in their house what
jerking off yeah
it's kind of sad [ __ ] you're engaged son
yeah i'm growing up
you went off the market what happened at
such a time you got drafted yeah you
just started to pop bro
dude this is the time when you catch a
freaking sex charge and you went the
other way
you ain't got to do that you went the
other way though yeah yeah i went the
other way
now i got a great girl man i got a
question where'd you meet her at
uh instagram she dm me hell yeah oh she
did me like
you're so funny what did she say
honestly can you share with us yeah
forget i mean i could probably look and
see it but she was just like uh how are
you doing a show anytime you know i
think you're funny or something like
that but she was just
she was like alpha female about it she
like she wanted she knew what she wanted
yeah she just went for it and she was
she's just [ __ ] dope no i got i got
super lucky and how'd you propose
uh we went to this it was like uh her
favorite restaurant and i just got down
on one knee and then
in the rest of it in the restaurant
during the middle of the let my boy
leave my boy just happened to be eating
there with his girl that he hasn't
proposed to you
living together for like three years and
so i see him there
and he sees me there and he's giving me
this look like oh you're not going to do
it
yeah and i'm like you better get the you
got 30 minutes
like this is burning a hole in my body
get the [ __ ] out of here
y'all just got salad you better [ __ ]
dude that is damaging to so many plates
you never even think about that if
you're going to do that
the people around you some pressure on
them their night like imagine they're
there for like they're together for like
four years god you're a good guy i've
been like yeah
[ __ ] that dude i mean that's the homie
yeah oh he's super close friends yeah
yeah my boy francis francis ellis comic
funny guy yeah francis ellis dude
you know new jersey with me yeah he
loves you he's great bro yeah he's great
he's great man he's seen he's like
really he's kind of
he's he started taking his relationship
seriously though
yeah he really should you don't think
his girl's seeing this girl
he should i'm busting paul no and pull
up a picture of francis francis there's
a lot of like
people that this is like the kind of if
you think of white people this is who
people i don't think i know francis
francis ellis uh francis is great man
and he did look at him i know francis
he's from uh
he did it barstool well he wasn't from
he wrote a blog about like that girl
that was that was dead or something
but he didn't know she was dead yeah
yeah like she was just missing and he
was like she was like a sugar girl or
whatever sugar
daddy sugar baby so he's like yeah he
shouldn't be a sugar baby and then the
girl ended up being dead but he's
writing this critical article like his
complete happenstance he came out to l.a
for a while i remember seeing him at the
store i know francis
he's great he's [ __ ] hilarious he's
beautiful
but also kind of a piece right he's kind
of a piece
he looks like uh from love island he's
like six six
oh he's a big man let's not go there
okay let's not go
i don't know if we go six six i would
say he's probably six four i'm gonna
give him six
four yeah maybe a six three i'll just
say six i've seen the guy
yeah let's say this bro he could have
played maybe third string power forward
for brown
brown yes that's where i'm gonna go
brown yes athletically with him
yeah but he's a rower like that's kind
of the uh the uh the
you know genealogies from that makes
sense they have a small boat they take
out for fun
what a good guy for you not to [ __ ]
propose in front of his girl
yeah i couldn't do it you couldn't do it
to the homie man that's a yeah that's a
solid move man
so do you all have a place now y'all
moving in together how rich are you
um i'm kind of kind of rich i don't know
not as rich as you guys but i think i'm
pretty rich
i'm this guy is you're really rich yeah
you know you are probably pretty rich
i'm not
yeah but you've been getting you know
what i realized somebody's stealing my
money don't let him fool you okay
he does well he just doesn't like to
spend any of it
no but that's then you should be even
more rich that's how money works yeah
but he like
takes his checks and put him in the back
of his car yeah what i got
i don't know anything about money my
friends i have them in a group chat
they're like bitcoins and twenty three
dollars i'm like i don't know what that
is i'm not i'm not investing in bitcoin
i can't invest in anything i don't know
anything about you're a business guy you
know what the [ __ ] up
i can make money off of things i know
yeah like i can
build we built the studio i had no clue
how i was gonna make money on it and
then a year later we're shooting a
netflix special in the studio
but that's how my brain works right if
i'm if i know what i'm doing
i can monetize you're investing in
yourself exactly i can invest in me and
i go
but if it's a t i don't know what att is
going to do and i get pissed off that i
can't help it mm-hmm you know what i
mean like 18t
stockings so many calls yeah i want to
call up 18 t and be like well i'm the
same i only invest in my own [ __ ]
okay well that's good that works but
then again i don't know i'm like
i would love to be really smart about
money but i i
i don't know i don't want you don't have
you don't what are you wasted on you
don't drive any cars or not nothing
nothing i'm wearing the same pants i
wore on the special right now wow oh
that's great
and the same sneakers and you have your
own merch on yeah
you don't spend your money either no no
i mean like
i'll go on a nice vacation yeah i'll go
to nice restaurants that's how i'll
spend that's probably spend the money
but yeah
who's this little man dude who do you
think this is
yeah it looks like for you i wish hey
what's up
i heard you guys were looking for some
culture in your corner esses
this is the cats in vatos corner now i
tried to get on fool's gone wild
they said nah homes you're too short
essay so i created my own [ __ ]
vatos in krakos
[Music]
this guy's hilarious
[Music]
none of my homies know about my little
setup right here because it's too
festive and they ain't with that gay
[ __ ]
but i'm gonna take a sip of my white
claw cause like they say
there ain't no laws when you're a vato
you want us to get down there on our own
but that's okay
cause i rob fools i'll rob a plane
ticket that's what
those do hey men bro if you guys want my
assistance
send me a dm all right holmes i'm out
later hasta luego papa dude it's these
[ __ ] net bangers and lames bro
mom we have any uh pizza rolls left
that was a good guy bravo what's his
name
all three of them he deserves a shout
out what's his name uh jordan uh
joseph fontana montana well done kiddo
that's total second generation latino in
america or they're not none of them
speak spanish anymore
it's all they're everybody's totally
he's also
italian yeah
dang that's dope man that's good i think
joseph fontana's gotta be in the lead so
are you guys gonna hire somebody how did
what's wrong with that i just want to
adjust like cat and uh chappelle are on
fighter in the kid all the time so we're
just trying to add in some just
diversify it so you're gonna get rid of
them no
are you guys assisting in but that's
your removal
now i'm seeing myself oh so you would
just get rid of these people right yeah
yeah
because it sounds like that's what he's
doing right yeah right
bro yo how do you say that to both of
them we need some diversity they are the
diversity
a black guy you guys helping
but who's black or do you think schultz
or chappelle put an ig swipe up put an
idea
it's got to be
[Music]
yeah but i see that and i
don't even know you were black can i say
what can i say one thing really quickly
uh dustin poirier has a hot sauce
incredible tbc is the promo code for ten
percent off
in the time is
i just love the sauce man look you know
what goes great with dustin pourier's
new hot sauce
andrew sold his new netflix show
they don't know [ __ ] about it bro i
literally just told them
we script the whole thing like an essay
and he goes so someone else comes on and
reads it with you
guess during my special
[Laughter]
have you seen netflix
y'all going to hell bro y'all going to
hades bro
i love you man and you know who you are
um what else we got yeah i've got a
couple more of these submissions uh i
got it's just
jordan fontana you really set the bar
high yeah it's okay we'll just make fun
of the other people's physical features
those here we go though here we go okay
what do we got what's up king and
staying sergio 22 from arcadia
california
just southeast of pasadena um yeah i'm
half native american and mexican on both
my mom's and my dad's side
i play guitar drums bass more recently
piano
uh yeah i've lived in my whole life my
uh family moved from highland park to
arcadia
a while ago and then uh yeah i run two
podcasts myself
big fan of the show i've been watching
you guys for a long time
he looks like uh john favreau and sarah
silverman
not a baby yeah doesn't he's john
feverish
do you guys know yeah slingers
the director of iron man's this guy
looks like he loses sleep over his
pronouns at night
are you guys friends with sarah i i like
sarah do you can you tell her to stop
doing all those like hollywood celebs
we're not racist videos
she shows up in every one oh i didn't
like her she did a special
like whenever uh the election was like
going she went to louisiana to
see how people think i thought it was
garbage she's funny though yeah no she's
funny but like it's funny why is she
doing every one of those she's like a
funny comic like usually funny people
don't do that funny people make fun of
that
i don't know that's i i sometimes i
think some people get
too far like in hollywood like too far
left
it's like that's yeah they just want to
be invited to do parties yeah they want
to be invited
yeah they want to be part of that group
and man that's a lonely world because
that
group's going to turn their back on you
and then you gotta look at real comics
you know
[Music]
i'm completely better oh yeah i'm naked
naked
i'm like naked behind me she got the
halves thought
you know it's some [ __ ] it's just like
hey i'm rich listen to me i [ __ ] hate
that [ __ ] bro do you
like borat uh you know what i like stack
with me though
the first one i like me too after that i
felt like it was just making fun of
people and then hiding behind lawyers
there you go yeah which is the most
ratchet [ __ ] i think you can look bro
real talk oh i'm so happy
because what he does is he just goes to
like where you're from and goes look how
stupid these people are yeah yeah that's
like his whole statement
yeah go do it in your hometown go do it
in your [ __ ] hometown where you came
from [ __ ] whatever you got dude
and then he goes yeah yep but here's the
thing that annoys me the most about him
is it
i'm fine if that's your prank show let's
say you just have a prank show
and that's what he does on showtime yeah
but that's fine and it's just a prank
show
but then he got up in one of these
[ __ ] award shows and goes i'm
exposing racism yes anti-semitism
he went too far left he went too far he
just got on a pedestal and it's like
dude you're
you have the lowest brow humor yeah okay
and you're just
making fun of people that were kind to
you yeah literally people like would you
like to come in my house [ __ ] them
over yeah and then he just [ __ ] them
over
it makes them look real stupid i didn't
know it was like that yeah
people don't know he goes he goes to
louisiana he goes and says he goes can i
come into your house with a stupid
accent the people go i don't even know
who you are
christian i feel like he's anti-white i
don't know i don't know what his deal is
bro but
yeah [ __ ] then it shits on everybody
it's just means
thanks thanks man and i hate i just
get off your [ __ ] high horse i
stopped watching off the first one
first one i was like all right i'm all
right but ali g was good man
but he was different then dude i love
the movies it was i and i'm fine with
you having the prank show if you just
come out and go yeah i'm a piece of [ __ ]
i prank people that's fine like i'm
totally fine with that great awesome
he's trying to act like he's a good
person
he's acting like he's saving the world
bro like he's
bringing light to you know he's a
[ __ ] charity called uh
uh stop hate for profit your whole show
is hate for profit that's what you do
that's his career drop it off with
people being bigoted
that you forced them to be bigoted yeah
yeah true
i just know that you like and how big it
is to go to a place and then be mean to
people
you know what i'm saying yeah but how
nice are these people horrible how nice
are these people to let them into their
homes and their businesses
you're taking it lights them on fire
yeah it's unbelievable and then he asks
them the inflammatory basically
go in their bathroom he shits in a bag
and he runs out of their house yelling
you hate black
what are we even people about and the
guy thinks he's some [ __ ] genius yeah
he stinks
yep i'm with you that's crazy man oh
[ __ ] yeah this is different because
they're coming into our house and we're
lighting them up so
it's about bro fair but we believe in
hatred
this dude's still trying to get on cats
yeah with wade robson bro let him talk
[Laughter]
dude andrew made us mean today
do you all remember wade robson at that
show where he was like judging people
that were going to be dancers
it was on mtv oh dude
damn man i shouldn't have said that man
no he didn't he did
michael jackson was launching his
family's launching a show in vegas
and he went to him and was like hey i
want to help out and like no we're good
we got people like now and he started
and then he did the documentary oh
really yeah after they turn him down
that's [ __ ] up yeah mj gave him his
career this guy has no career if mj
doesn't say hey you're really good at
dancing and when he was in perth
australia since he was a kid
yeah let's look at this sexy son of a
[ __ ]
as you may have heard i'm running for my
channel
why you should vote for me
because i may look mexican but i'm
actually not
why else who else is inc
do you want to sink while ripping their
drip damn
who's right do you want to chive
killing it bro you can't clown my hound
but you can roast my wall
oh damn that's jack london i'm just a
cajun boy
from mesa arizona you say the word i'm
on my way
gang
it was about to be haymakers you're from
mesa yeah i'm from mexico
and that's awesome yeah good for him
wade robson bro
look at that soul patch that was a
choice
the whole you know the whole get up was
a choice the ears the earrings
yeah yeah you don't think jackson did
anything to him
robson no you don't think did you think
he smoked out any of those kids
no nothing so smoked out but no
don't say smoked out why that makes you
feel weird but
bro i got to tell this should make you
feel weird i gotta tell them
smoked out yeah but smoked out is better
than banging yeah you're right it is
brendan
smoked out's weird what if somebody said
hey you want this brisket we've been
banging it
yeah and someone said yo this brisket is
banging
dude get me some of that but okay what
else what else
should we say what is better what is
better for like yeah what would you
rather how would you rather us talk
about kids getting [ __ ] you don't
think you touched those kids
touched his teeth she's better that
could be anything
you know accidentally bumping into
somebody at the mall no
not if you're like hanging out what if
he's rinsing kid's cheeks
holy [ __ ] that's kind of what that's
better than smoked out okay fair enough
who's blacker
75 pig schultzy i don't believe it
chappelle
we don't believe in cultural
appropriations i agree bro actually
what's wrong with the cultural property
i'll do a little but i ain't doing a lot
bro you feel
a little bit you're doing just enough to
keep your career no i mean i'll [ __ ]
you know roll down the windows and
[ __ ] you know
live my life a little and [ __ ] like what
in nashville you can do that you know
but i won't do anything
real real crazy yo what up king of the
sting it's your boy pariah p
aka pariah like mariah with a p and i'm
here to explain why i would be the best
guest for the culture corner so
basically
i know this show is obsessed with white
rappers that i'm a white rapper
myself i was hand selected to open up
for dogecat brandon i know that you just
your son one of their favorite artists
is those guys i've sold out multiple
videos here in phoenix arizona
she felt like what's up mesa salute
club ryan nonquito
i know that you have polish man i'm
fully polished bro both of my parents
were born in poland
okay and cat you know i'm saying cat is
just a gorgeous woman asian women are
kind of my oh
that's what that's my [ __ ] that's my
weakness nick i know you lived in your
car for a minute i was couch surfing
like all 2018 so let me know
i can easily get out there it's
connecting man i love it i like this guy
watching the show every single week so
just let me know
hey man bro nice young man i just like
him yeah sweetie
he is there's something nice about him
there's ryan cabrera right there man he
just got engaged actually
to whom did he he is makeup on like a
[ __ ]
picture to alexa she's a wrestler
uh wwe um alexa
yeah that's right he just got engaged
man he's a nice guy bro
he's a sweet guy he is man i i've you
know been a ton of parties and stuff
with him over the years yeah he's a nice
dude
what is it really
well i didn't know you and brian cabrera
were [ __ ]
best friends bye bad friends
he's in full [ __ ] makeup in that
picture that's not him that's alexa
bliss
no go back to the the where he's in uh
the set of twilight
um crazy
what is happening bro that's the set of
twilight zones
the [ __ ] out what is the hair dude can
we call him and just
ask about the hair he's that hair crow
bro you know
chris
there ain't a bird getting in the garden
around now bro dude you know he dated um
remember he dated jessica simpson's
sister do you guys remember that yeah
yeah yeah ashley simpson does this work
yeah ashley simpson had that oh she's
married to diana ross's kid
yeah she had that beak forever then got
the nose oh she got the nose job yeah
she looks bad now
look at that who's that you know what's
going on
dude don't [ __ ] act like whatever
that is bro he was in the movie atlanta
kid credit evan ross or 18 he was in the
movie atl
i don't know who he is diana ross's uh
son dude that's lester holt bro y'all
[ __ ]
y'all out here slipping on leicester dog
that's my boy right there
bruh that's a that's a look right there
but ashley simpson kind of turned into a
little piece
i told you she got that beak done and
yeah you could really carve yourself
into something i thought she's pretty
before i thought she
i like that beak on her no you like the
beak you're a big fan of beak
i mean you come i got a beak bro so i
gotta go you don't have a dude
you don't have a beak dude potato you
got a potato
nah you got a potato that's a beak that
got a potato and mine's kind of a mix of
both yeah yours has been mad you're
fine bro don't try to fit into the
[ __ ] big
you don't you're you have a wide nose
burning old text like i think i have
small
shoulders i'm like [ __ ] who gives
you're [ __ ] out of your mind he
always tries to
fit into these different groups
[Laughter]
dude i'm not trying to fit into your
group you built like my aunt
you're just jealous i went freaking
skiing and you didn't go you freaked
you hit them slowpieces
come on full circle dog close oh
dude don't full circle they don't have a
full circle
racism
[Laughter]
what else we got nick oh oh [ __ ] it's
gifts
are we going what are we doing what are
we doing yeah schultz can start i open
yeah you open your gift and then oh and
this is the gift okay
so this is my gift this is part of my
gift right this is it goes
live to live to make people laugh i
can't read that's fire thank you very
much
can you see the camera okay i'll show it
to the camera sorry which one am i
this one this one here look at that oh
that's a bad one that's cool
who brought that i did
thank you man someone mailed that to me
i have no clue send it to me either
thank you this is a lot of smoothie
mixes oh that's athletic greens that's
it chroma code cats they gave us
if you want more promo code cats and
liquid iv yup
stay hydrated all right you and your
girl in hawaii there's one more thing
this is uh dustin poirier's
[Laughter]
dang i wish i had to put some i'm gonna
open mine now i got these baby somebody
gave me this oh damn that's mine
so i uh damn baby in the punk rock world
we used to wear bullet belts
that's a belt yeah it's a belt you don't
wear around your neck you're wearing
around your head damn hot topic was open
during these hours
not a thought topic brother those are
those are real bullets so yeah
be careful so don't get too hot in those
yeah these 44s or something i don't know
my buddy gave me that uh 48. back in
like 0-9
on the bottom 48. that's dope i wish we
would have played this white elephant
i know yeah that's actually yeah
percocet all right open this one hit a
shot
let's go shabba
dang what's this anyone got keys
get in there hey what'd you get man
this one's for me this was your gift
yeah
and we got christmas bonuses for
everybody on the show too so we just
want to let you all know that
oh [ __ ] sick who said [ __ ] sick
nick he's [ __ ] sick nick's always
about goddamn time
he's like nah that's cool though oh this
is cool
show us princesses
[Laughter]
what is it the hottest have you ever had
one of those i don't do that that'd be a
great answer i don't play that [ __ ]
you want one you wanna go i do not play
that you like views
can you do it alex can eat spicy stuff
do you want to try it
half half half i wouldn't even have the
little tiny little piece
come on al take a bite come on now come
on come on
come on come on now yeah i'll direct it
special al directed it i'll directed it
yeah how would this because
directorial debut was a netflix special
oh hell yeah man congratulations
i'll give you this we've all done it to
be honest the fit is clean the pine
jordans come on son come on i'm going to
be leaking out my ass
no you know i'm not gross don't don't
touch your eyes or anything after
yeah yeah don't don't i'm not having any
of it no
i'm not having it yeah i already did
yeah direct us through this bro yeah
direct us through
it
real quick real quick who's this from
china here we go alex media has taken
down the hottest chip in the world
challenge
[Laughter]
the real challenge is not to have any
fluids that's what the tic-tac-toe yeah
you can't have anything in that right
man
so do whatever you want yeah yeah yeah
just how do you feel
now wipe your hands before you touch
your face you don't want to get that
how is it it's just a ride yeah it's
like it gets
it's not fun you're good or what
yeah it's not fun it's not fun
you feel yeah no snow pumps
i drank [ __ ] room temperature milk to
get over it and i got real sick
yeah the milk was the bad choice yeah
what else we got chapelle do you open
yours up
uh i got chins just opened it up okay he
re-gifted
i got myself 3d printed okay
from last year from last night okay turn
that's awesome that was a good gift
yeah i'm glad i got it is he crying he's
crying bro
i can't believe you took that much shaq
couldn't do that right didn't shaq start
crying
i don't know do you do it yeah still
cried you cried on that i think i did
but i cry usually every other episode
i i i panicked at first i panicked
is it still there it is it's not going
away no it's really not
it's gonna be about an hour yeah
20 minutes you're going to get a second
hit no it comes back strong
and then when you hit that toilet son
that's not true i think you're going to
be fine and i think these people are
overreacting
[Laughter]
oh you're right deal than eat one no
it's just white people trying to scare
you bro that's what it is
and we've seen enough of that [ __ ] i
think no we have with this covet [ __ ]
yeah chappelle you got one you got one
oh yeah
oh man this one i brought for
so in you asian community we hate the
sun because we don't want to age
and we wear these visors hell yeah wow
so you're going to look like every old
asian lady in the park doing tai chi
super asian gift that's super easy
damn dog make some weld some jewelry son
that shit's dope
dude you gotta [ __ ] work with nelly
now yeah you [ __ ] gotta get in there
i know it's [ __ ] up bro cover your
face dude
did you go through yours that's how
cat's gonna introduce you to her family
that's a great gift man
hey cat have fun in the movies in 2022.
there's gonna be some good stuff coming
out looking for the avatar three yeah
yeah yup we think they're special by
then so i can go watch it
yes it will be in theaters yeah it'll be
only in the
heart style switch it up you think they
they zig you zag
hey i can see that being a thing where
specials the first place they come out
is maybe in the theater
remember when martin did that back in
the day when we were younger yeah martin
had one come out eddie did probably
oh that's cool that's like that's nice
of you this is like michael scott
bringing the
ipod
and sardines and ramen and sardines and
ramen oh you got that
yeah that's a dowry kid in asia he
marries someone you give that in asia
yeah dude that's [ __ ] hell yeah you
get two [ __ ] you give that in asia
i do what'd you get thank you brandon
his cbd company
yeah that's not the new new but it's
cool
that's overstock but yeah kratom
me and chen are addicted to kratom yeah
we are going on that pouch
kratom is a supplement
that's supposed to help your brain how
would you describe how would you
describe your chin
uh it's just a powdered leaf it's from a
tree
it was used in thailand for thousands of
years
they say it's kind of like the fda wants
to stop it because it gives some sort of
an opiate type of effect but means
it's supposed to be safe it's natural me
and chin like but it's actually really
good
uh if you want to use it for pain and
for know anxiety i i take it before i
experience
stage yeah it's like cbd all the time
and you just have to take it every day
otherwise you go through violence
withdrawals
yeah that's the part i mean some people
some people do but then that's why you
got to just watch yourself
violent withdrawals just don't do it if
you don't need to vernon's next comedy
show
withdrawals that's a great special title
now was it hard to do oh was it what was
it like
directing the special take us through
some of that it was uh it was scary
yeah i never been on like a production
of that size before
now there's me an onslaught of shitty
comics hitting you up to direct their
specials
good get that money out yeah good why
not we gotta do it now he did it
he did a great job what's up everybody
holla
he did amazing job he also edited the
special and uh he learned how to use
premiere which we edited on eight days
before we actually did the special
way hey uh crazy
oh cause you were doing final cut
because it's easier well i don't know
you explain it better just for a podcast
it's like a faster turnover and so i
just do most of my editing there
should say did you uh help with the
editing
these guys are the experts but like i
said but you want to see it
yeah i have to see everything and like
mark as well was editing there's this
guy named john raffanelli we got to
shout this guy he was absolutely amazing
he's not like part of our team but i
literally was telling the production
company that we hired
we're going to steal him yeah because he
was just so dedicated to it was
unbelievable
but um but yeah like they both worked
off of premiere and they just
they would [ __ ] kill it and i
basically get to like go in and sit in
and say i think i like this a little bit
more why we try this that the other but
i mean these guys just murdered it it
was great but imagine eight days before
just to learn premiere i'd walk into the
editing bay and he'd have one screen up
and it was just youtube like how to do
something he did it and then he'd
[ __ ] do it
that grassroots nature man i love that
man that's been a theme years the whole
time got investing your people bro
amen dude no christmas bonuses but you
guys
[Laughter]
thank you so much for coming man merry
christmas to everybody out there
i'll be in palm beach florida palm beach
improv that is december
29th through january 2nd with the squad
and then thick boy smiley gear just drop
thickboy.com yeah january 15th i got
that live show with chelsea lynn
um that we're gonna do so you can get a
ticket to that now and then let let the
fans know that i'll be co-hosting the
episodes uh for the month of january
yeah
oh yeah and brandon will be co-hosting
the episode tim dillon we got some other
fun guests for you
tim dillon uh christa stefano who almost
made it but it couldn't his career just
didn't happen for him
chris roasted us on the last episode
he's sending a video what did he say you
said based saying i wish
got in rogan two years ago when you guys
did
he's like you got another exact time i'm
still waiting to get on so i can sell
tickets and [ __ ]
that's it that's it um thank you guys so
much andrew
yeah thank you i appreciate it i feel
like this whole thing's been a promotion
for a special
yeah kind of no i appreciate you all
having me thank you
if you guys want to go check it out on
netflix and if you don't that's cool too
alex get well man
congratulations on your first special
man yeah i appreciate you guys
brendan and theo fighter and weight i
got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
burning ate the queso and the quesoritos
but
everything's gonna be fine hate on me i
do not mind
theo looking like the type of dude that
got a pack of matches in his pockets at
all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
triba couldn't beat him
quit playing like nintendo diaz you
don't want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up oh
yeah
king inner sting
[Music]
on a string
[Music]
you